hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast melanoma view from the front
lines of the immunotherapy and precision
medicine i'm kristina jewel of a group
and i'll be a moderator for today's
event today's webcast is presented by
lab roots calm deleting social media
site for science professionals before we
start there are a few instructions this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credit please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits we want to hear from you during
this interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment answers
are welcome to you can do this by
hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can emerge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top light or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenter we are proud to
welcome Louise Perkins PhD chief science
officer at the melanoma Research
Alliance
dr. Perkins is responsible for the
development and implementation of the mr
a's scientific strategy her entrance
center on translational research
including genomics drug discovery and
advancement of novel therapeutic
approaches dr. Perkins became a member
of the board of directors of the
foundation of starving sarcoidosis
research in 2015 prior to joining the
ammo raid she served as chief scientific
officer at the multiple myeloma Research
Foundation for five years where she led
the expansion of its venture
philanthropy activities including
biotech investment award program and the
development of the scientific direction
of its compound wanted to know more
study previously at the director as the
director of cancer research at their
pharmaceuticals dr. Perkins contributed
to advancing novel targeted therapies
toward clinical studies and at the
schering-plough Research Institute she
led a cancer research group
participating in early-stage programs
her complete bio was found on the lab
Bruce welcome please join me in
welcoming dr. Louise Perkins dr. Perkins
this is Louise Perkins I'm the chief
science officer at the melanoma Research
Alliance and it's my pleasure to speak
with you today about a subject is very
important to us at the melanoma Research
Alliance the view from the front lines
of immunotherapy and precision medicine
which is where we are in melanoma right
now as we get started I want to just
give you a little bit of history about
melanoma Research Alliance which
provides an orientation to where we are
and why I think this is such an
important subject the melanoma Research
Alliance was founded in 2007 by Deborah
alien black shortly after Deborah's
diagnosis with melanoma her Paris come
together very well but she was
challenged at that point in time to
establish in melanoma a foundation
committed to the elimination
and death very much in the image of the
prostate cancer foundation and we were
created under the auspices of the Milken
Institute in order to achieve that
mission so since that time MRA has been
able to become the largest private
plunger of melanoma research we have
awarded over 79 million dollars to
researchers around the world all in
academic institutions and we have an
expectation this year coming up in 2017
to award at least 7 million dollars more
for research covering the gamut of
established investigators science early
career investigators pilot awards for
early emerging thing with strong
hypothesis as well as for industry
partnership programs likewise one other
key feature of our program is that we
are very much committed to
interdisciplinary team science and
although we are not funding it this year
we have supported on nearly two-thirds
of dollars that we've provided for this
kind of interdisciplinary work just
wrapping up on mr a our focus is on
translational research we have awarded
individuals and teams as i said and
about eighty-five percent pushing ninety
actually is the fraction of our dollars
that have gone to treatment related
science with the balance in prevention
and new diagnostics so that's a history
of MRA and you can see that we're really
passionate about the field about working
towards our mission with all of the
stakeholders in the business so with
that then i'm going to just push on and
give you a brief introduction to the
agenda for the session and once i get
through this i'll ask my colleagues to
push out the polls so what we'll cover
is an overview of melanoma and the
biology of melanoma actually provides
the basis for the treatments that have
emerged and also provides Hamptons to
where we can go in the future I'll cover
some of those treatments and really the
fantastic progress that has happened to
date from immunotherapy to precision
medicine targeted therapy
and then just wrap up very quickly with
some comments on the future and where I
think things will be going for the view
so um if we could have the polls go out
that would be great so let me move on to
the melanoma overview I'm going to cover
a little bit about the facts and figures
of the disease some of the biology and
then touch on really come to keep first
that melanoma have finds itself in so
first of all you should see that
melanoma incidents is rising the
statistics shown on the right-hand part
of the slide illustrate the increase in
melanoma new diagnoses 400,000 people
this is just us data and I just pulled
it down from the seer website recently
you can see there's an a steady increase
in fact a tripling of a new diagnosis
for melanoma and that lower flat line
that really doesn't change shows that
deaths have pretty much remained flat in
fact in the US this year there are
approximately seventy six thousand new
diagnosis expected and 10 pounds and
death unfortunately the median diagnosis
from melanoma is at about 52 years of
age and it is the most common cancer
diagnosed in 25 to 29 year olds some
people hypothesize that this has
something to do with the use of tanning
beds sun exposure that sort of thing and
almost certainly those things do
contribute to the onset of melanoma as
you'll see and genesis of melanoma due
to dynamic changes in a few slides you
can tell by this great Delta between the
new diagnosis and the death rate that
clearly melanoma when it's caught early
can be managed very well in surgery of
the mainstay in that management however
it gets caught in the advanced stages
when it's spread to distant organs there
is a poor five-year survival of about
fifteen percent so the overview for
melanoma and its incidence in various
populations demonstrates
that melanoma has the highest incidents
in fair skinned individuals if you look
at the top of this slide you'll see that
for the white race that there are the
largest number of cases of melanoma the
fact is that melanoma is more common in
males than in females but if you look at
other individuals with darker
complexions a melanoma indeed is present
and diagnose that a measurable rate in
fact I can think of many individuals who
have unfortunately been diagnosed who
have darker complexions and so it just
points out that melanoma can affect
anyone but indeed the vast majority of
melanoma patients are fair-skinned
individuals individuals like myself who
have a propensity to the disease or a
variety of reasons and a little bit
about how melonova presents in the
clinic is shown in this slide you can
see beginning at the top left and
walking from panels a through E that
cutaneous melanoma melanoma occurs in
multiple sites with different
presentations at the top left in panel a
superficial spreading melanoma is the
most common presentation of melanoma in
the clinic panel b shows a melanoma that
actually is a melanotic in other words
it's lost its expression of melanin the
dark pigment and it is that known in
pigment pigment which is the pigment
that protects us from sun damage panel c
shows a nodular melanoma and listening
to the dermatologist who are
participants on our various scientific
advisory panels leads me to believe that
these modular melanomas are difficult to
diagnose and dangerous when they're
diagnosed so these are a particular
challenge and that'll be a coal
indigenous melanoma April melanoma
occurs on the palms of the hands soles
of the feet and under the fingernails
on this is the kind of melanoma that
actually is most frequently presented in
patients with darker complexions and
finally ocular melanoma is particularly
one in the back of the eye so these are
some of the presentations of melanoma
and this next slide on melanoma biology
shows the genesis of the disease given
the size of this particular illustration
I'm not going to be able to go through
it in a great deal of detail I do want
to point out to you that as you can see
kind of in the middle of this panel
beginning that stage zero in stage one
at the bottom that melanoma forms in the
pigment producing cells of the skin the
melanocytes that dark Squatch in the
middle of the panel above the stage is
zero text would be the earliest
presentation of melanoma but as with
many tumors as it grows larger and
invades more deeply into the surrounding
tissue it becomes increasingly dangerous
and you can see as you progress to the
far right that these deep thick
melanomas are the ones that are the
stage for melanomas that are
particularly vexing in clinic and are
the most dangerous now what what drives
the formation of melanoma and how does
this help us as new treatments have been
discovered over time well what's been
observed in sequencing studies and there
are many of them including the TCGA
studies and work that's been done Yale
and other centers studies that we
ourselves have supported with tegan
reading and genomics work shows that
melanoma is in fact the cancer with the
highest mutational rate of any ten
certain sequence to date in this
particular chart you can see on a
logarithmic scale on the y-axis and
highlighted at the far right that the
red box surrounding the melanoma samples
illustrates that melanoma has the
largest number of mutations per megabase
of all of the cancers analyzed and if
you look at the bottom of that redbox
region you'll see the block of yellow
color at the bottom that block of yellow
color illustrates the kinds of mutations
that are observed in melanoma there is a
predominance of CT transitions observed
in melanoma which are hallmark of
uv-induced damage so that signature of
UV exposure really provides us along
with the information that there are many
many mutations seen across melanoma
tumor genomes that there is in fact a
mutational event that contributes to the
driving of this disease and also helps
us to at least think about and provides
food for thought as to why melanoma may
in fact be the most energetic of the
cancers and may be particularly
responsive to treatments that reengage
the immune system in the treatment of
melanoma so I'll come back to that point
about the role of mutations in the
production of the new antigens so called
neolution in a moment just spending a
second to talk about knowing all the
targets specifically what we know from
the analysis of melanoma genomes looking
at the whole exome sequencing out w es
that the signaling through the raft raft
neck pathway is clearly dysregulated in
no numa at the top of this chart in work
from michael krop palmer and now you can
see that in this set of samples there
were about forty percent of the melanoma
trailers that were analyzed that had
mutations in one of the three raft
proteins he left here at is the most
frequently mutated target in melanoma so
this is been seen in the variety of
samples and indeed the predominance of
mutations there are mutations at the 600
position from the v2 and E so v600e
mutation through the most common and
that's shown at that top left red
that showed at that top graph left red
block of the panel here the rest of the
mutations that are shown are in rafts
that's a predominant set of mutations
and the rasp protein that is the target
for mutations actually is n mass and the
and Rask mutations that are seeing our
activating mutations and those are
occurred about fifteen to twenty percent
in most samples that have been analyzed
across all of melanoma I would actually
point you to another resource for
looking at tumor genomics and melanoma
genomics in particular and that is the
sea bio portal it's see bio Cordle gorg
that can be found it's a great tool to
noodle around on on tumor genomes if you
have that interest the other part that I
wanted to point you to is that there are
other mutations that are seen in
melanomas that again confirm the wrong
for Rath signaling through the ref net
or pathway come n f1 which is a GTP ace
activating protein which turns off grass
signals is also mutated and is
inactivated in some melanomas and then
across the rest of the genome of
melanoma samples that have been analyzed
you see some usual suspects like p53
heat n you see cdkn2a mutations and and
also other cdk4 activating cdk4 286
activating mutations across melanomas so
that's kind of a deep dive into what
drives melanoma we know a fair bit about
it and fortunately some targets have
occurred from this information and these
targets have been driven into
therapeutics indeed there have been a
number of firsts from melanoma based on
all of this biology and I've summarized
this on this slide 11 here really
leading the way
you know therapy and precision medicine
this is what melanoma has seen happen
since the first approvals of the first
immunotherapy for any cancer the first
checkpoint drove for any cancer that
should say with Ibelin oh man in 2011
and most recently the first checkpoint
therapy for the adjuvant treatment of
melanoma if a little nabor if he has it
sometime call sometimes called was
approved for that by the fda in 2015
likewise the first b-raf inhibitor
approved for any therapy was them you're
a sodden with its approval in 2011 and I
should point out that the approval of
iffy and them in 2011 when the first
approvals for melanoma in over a decade
and really started this landslide of
progress that we've seen in the melanoma
space there have been many other first
for both melanoma and for other
counselors that this work has enabled
the first MEK inhibitor approved in any
cancer preventing them the first
combination approval in melanoma of
dobrze handed and fermented the first
chance of keeping one drug approved in
the u.s. embolism at in 2014 the first
approval of any pd1 drug around the
world was nivo was approved earlier in
japan first checkpoint combination
therapy of if he an EVO in any cancer in
2015 t vac the first oncolytic
virotherapy was approved in melanoma and
gonna wrap and have been coding that nib
showed that you can in fact approve an
agent in combination where there is no
single agent approval kobe magnum is not
approved as a single agent for melanoma
and us only in combination with in the
afternoon many many firsts seen in the
melanoma field and we think that this is
really just a clear demonstration of
progress for the field I'd like to bring
up the results of the poll if I could
help that so the first poll question was
to pull the audience's interest in the
top
thick of the presentation today I'm
interested in this topic from the
perspective of cancer patient or patient
care giver scientists clinician or other
most people on the phone about
three-quarters of you are scientists and
the rest said that you fell into the
other category the details for the
second poll question I have myself or I
have a patient friend who has received
immunotherapy targeted therapy who
participated in a clinical trial it's
quite interesting the about just under
half of folks have a targeted therapy
say that they have or have a patient
friend who's received targeted therapy
and about a third immunotherapy and just
under a quarter have participated in the
clinical trial it is not a typical
population of people I think based on
that but I appreciate your interest in
that and hopefully you'll learn some
more about this particular field and how
it applies to many other cancers in the
future so moving on with the
presentation just to summarize for
melanoma overall as i mentioned
sun-exposed melanoma has the highest
mutational rate of any cancer they're
prevalent mutations in the beer and rasp
pathway personalized medicines have been
developed that target these including a
number of drugs that I'll come back to
later in the presentation to reveal
antigens from mutations as well as
Sharon antigens I should mention it's
not just all about Neil antigens here to
be providing targets for the immune
system to react to melanoma and there
have been numerous versed in the
treatment of cancers that have emerged
building from these Disney's features
and years of research so let's move on
now to immunotherapy and melanoma just a
little bit of background on this
particular topic it's been known for
some time that melanoma is one of the
most in the response of cancers dr.
Coley used infections of
turn-of-the-century to target cancer for
a variety of reasons related to
unsteadiness of results and toxicities
has proved not to be
a therapeutic approach with the blasting
legs however high-dose interleukin-2 was
a prick melanoma by the FDA in 1998 in
the maintains the melanoma as does
interferon and interference approved as
adjuvant therapy in two thousand eleven
to one of the earliest of the several
early immunotherapies approved for
melanoma but there are significant
dose-related toxicities with the use of
these agents and somewhat limited
activity in terms of get sponsoring it
doesn't really spurred the interest in
developing newer approaches what are
some of those newer approaches this
particular slide really just summarizes
that some of the vast biology in the
area of in the therapy this is a very
simplified view of some of the key
features that enable the working of
immunotherapy in melanoma if you look at
the top left of this slide you can see
peptide or tumor vaccines as an
opportunity for use to stimulate the
therapeutic responses and the lower left
cellular immunotherapy another approach
that's gained a lot of traction in some
cancers in particular than hematological
malignancies and is still being studied
and been studied aggressively in
melanoma but is still the center a lot
of other work biological response
modifiers such as the interleukin cefiro
and I already mentioned shown at the
lower right but the use of monoclonal
antibodies to trigger different
reactions to reengage in the immune
system this has become one of the
central features of melanoma treatment
and also is a very new tool that's
allowing a lot of work in a lot of other
areas and why why is this of interest
and how does this work two agents that
have gained two approaches I should say
that if gained approval are approaches
that target ctla4 exemplified by the
approved drug if aluminum and anti pd-1
drugs that have been approved our pember
lism ab
nivolumab how do these work if you look
at the tumor cell depicted on the right
hand side of this image you can see the
tumor cells as part of how they go about
evading a system Express on their
surface markers that turn off activated
t-cells that would otherwise react to
these tumors and foreign antigens or
shared antigens that are recognized with
cane foreign and these activated t-cells
would then go about and target to the
tumor cell and fill it but because of
the signals being presented on the tumor
cell the T cells are turned off and
what's been shown is that through the
use of monoclonal antibodies like a
feminine ad targeting ctla-4 dressed on
the surface of the T cell or pd-1 using
either PEM bro or noodle express moment
he were those antibodies target the PT 1
on the t cell surface the disruption in
signaling between the cell surface
markers on the t cells and the tumor
cells enables a reinvigorated and mean
response and some of these responses
have turned into very strong benefit for
patients in particular and data that was
presented in 2013 by dirk sean dork
though there actually is tenure survival
for patients treated with the ctla-4
antibody mmm and it's actually at about
twenty percent of patients so if you
look at the blue curve here you can see
that round about three years after
treatment for of patients with advanced
metastatic melanoma so these are
patients who would have otherwise had
about fifteen percent five-year survival
you can see that their survival flattens
out at around one out of five at around
twenty percent and that overall survival
is durable for out to ten years really
quite remarkable and although a modest
improvement over what it's been expected
an amazing improvement for these
patients how do we improve on it from if
a lemon lab was the question that is
addressed by the field and the emergence
of pd-1 as
has really been a major benefit in that
so here's the next series of slides talk
a little bit about the activity of these
pd1 antibodies for example using member
lisabetha as one drug on this particular
slide you can see that there were two
schedules of Pemba lism and tested and
every three weeks schedule in orange and
in every two weeks schedule in blue it's
the every three weeks schedule that was
actually the one that was approved by
the FDA but in both cases what you can
see in this overall survival curve out
to 18 months is that treatment with the
anti pd-1 antibody did in fact improve
the overall survival of these patients
relatives to illuminate alone in this
relatively short time frame this is
likewise true for nivolumab alone the
pd-1 antibody nivo alone or nebo an iffy
in combination so the draw your
attention to the blue curve which is
nebo alone the orange curve which is
Nebo and hippie compared to the green if
women have occurred alone and here's
looking at progression-free survival as
the end point you can see that either
nivo or if he an evil in combination
appear to have a market improvement of
PFS compared to implement a balloon so
these drugs are actually very much
changing the face of cancer care not
only for melanoma but for other cancers
now combination therapy is frequently
used in cancer and we know it's very
important but often with combinations
here becomes additional classes V and
indeed and the dosing schedule used for
if you an EVO that is demonstrating some
tremendous benefit you can see that
there have been observed about fifty
percent of patients with grade 3 4 80 s
and that compares to about twenty to
twenty-four percent of patients
experiencing grapefruit for adverse
events in in patients treated with
aluminum
these side effects are significant
enough that about half of patients
discontinued treatment if you look at
the panel on the right hand slide of
side of this slide you can see a
swimmer's plot the blue part are the
patients who remain on treatment at the
portion of time during which those
patients remained on treatment the red
part the treatment the post treatment
discontinuation timeframe the black
arrows at the end of the each of them
lames an ongoing response observed and
then at the bottom sort of the vast
majority of this is for if he an evil in
combination and at the bottom that's the
comparison to people in the mouth alone
what this illustrates is that there were
a lot of treatment discontinuations that
took place but and interestingly
responses continued after those
treatment discontinuation and it's an
important question for the field overall
to explore what is the right dose what
is the right combination what is the
right schedule when is the right
duration treatment and kudos to the
developers for pushing things a head
wound up to our researchers for pushing
things ahead quickly to get these
treatments out the patients as soon as
possible but refining all of those
things is the subject of a lot of
research that's going on right now a
picture's worth a thousand words and I
wanted to just show you one of the
dramatic effects that's been published
in the New England Journal in a case
report of a very rapid dramatic effect
of the combination of if you need on a
patient this shows that the top left the
image of melanoma de was protruding from
the body wall of this particular
individual you can see the photo on the
top left and CT scan on the lower left
of that large mass with the star in the
center of it in the middle left of that
lower milk panel just a few weeks after
treatment with the combination as you
can see on the top right this mask
resolved itself and created essentially
a hole in the body wall and then
lower right you can see several weeks
after that and complete resolution of
that mess this is obviously a dramatic
and remarkable response and the sort of
thing that drives the kind of increased
interest that there is in combining
multiple checkpoint inhibitors not only
with money particularly for targeting
activity but also with other drugs of
the need for me given the side effect
profile however one of the questions
that commonly asked is how do we use
these drugs and the right patients at
the right time are they to be used for
everyone but are biomarkers that help us
to understand in whom they ought to be
used better this is a nice summary that
was done by doctors sunshine and health
at Johns Hopkins looking at across a
variety of clinical programs studying
the ante pd-1 erika bodies on the left
we've only lab and can deliver map and
ftp dl1 kind of sister antibodies on the
right and putting together all of this
data looking at one key question does
pl1 expressions that is the ligand for
PT 1 the PDL one expression relate to
response to ntpd one for aunty PDL month
era p and if so in what way and what
about PDL one negative patients so I'll
just focus you on the nivolumab melanoma
data which is the second set of bars on
the far left and you can see that in the
red bar the PDL one positive patients
have a more pronounced response then the
green bar the PDL one negative patients
and that general pattern if you scan
across this whole chart seems to play
itself out PDL one positive patients
have a more pronounced response to pd
one or pl1 based therapy as compared to
their PDL one- counterparts however the
you will see that the PDL one negative
patients do in fact have a measurable
response
and so what this tells us is that this
is a helpful file marker in some ways
but not a perfect autumn record and
these observations have driven the field
to continue to look at many many other
approaches Pam Sharma for example from
md anderson and event apollyon from john
hopkins have noted that he dl 1
expression NPD one expression are not
stable over time they go up they go down
and so it might be that there are other
more complex biomarkers that may need to
be used and there may be other things
like imaging or other markers that could
be used to help us to understand who are
the right patients to receive these
kinds of therapies to avoid toxicities
and to garner the benefit of these kinds
of treatments so I'm going to wrap up
the presentation part on immunotherapy
now and move on to precision medicine or
targeted therapy in melanoma as I
mentioned in thinking about the kinds of
mutations that one sees in melanoma they
are central in centrally seen in the
signaling through the wrath wrath nectar
pathway this is a simplistic depiction
of signaling through that pathway I'm
going to try to do a little mark up on
this slide to help focus our thoughts so
the general outline of signaling in this
kind of schema as most of you would know
is that a signal emerges from receptor
tyrosine kinase shown at the top left it
impinges on rafts there are multiple
rass isoforms and that seems to be
important in biology rasp then activates
graph and there are multiple graphitic
ones as well raf can also be activated
by mutation are shown here with the
v600e activated raf protein but the
ultimate output of that is the RAF
activates map via phosphorylation neck
then activates work via phosphorylation
and then Kirk which is itself a kinase
goes on to activate by possible relation
the series of downstream targets which
all turn on growth in the
various ways in cells now one thing I
wanted to point out which is important
is that n Rask is the most commonly
mutation we activated form of grass and
non-roma when you look at different
genomics you know what profiles in
melanoma there is a small rate of H
graphs mutational activation that can be
seen unlike hey rats which is pretty
sparse in melanoma but very commonly
mutation reactivated in a variety of
encounters a trusted is interesting in
that a trust is like all of the other
rats protein needs to be attached to the
plasma membrane via an isoprenaline tail
which is typically a farce elated kale
harnessing kale that embeds grass in the
plasma membrane and our drugs developed
when I was a real asking Pharma that
target farnesyltransferase but the
biology turns out that only a trap can
be completely inhibited by poor
insulation in addition the other grass
proteins can go on and be alternatively
crenellated through geranyl Darren
elation so a trois remains an
interesting target and some have some
groups have gone on to try to move ahead
the parcel transferase inhibitors that
were developed at that time into more
recent clinical trials so I think that
is an interesting kind of ultra orphan
situation in the case of melanoma but
something to think about for the future
but to really focus in now on what are
the regulatory approvals in melanoma for
various inhibitors in this pathway they
are vendor active to Bracken in the Arab
exhibitors from metonym and combination
therapies with two grafted connected
vendor a chemical metonym there are
other agents that are in under clinical
investigation and some of them are shown
here including a vtx 11e which is being
developed now by vitamin Valley I
believe and the shearing Burke inhibitor
7729 84 I'm not exactly sure of the
status of death
to the drug but there wasn't early
clinical development on that that was
interesting so I'm interrupting
signaling through this pathway seemed
like an obvious way it seems like an
obvious way to interfere with melanoma
tumor growth what one sees is that there
you need to do this in patients who have
a v600 mutation for them you're a fan
event to graph and investigate 600e the
response in these patients is about half
of patients experience responds and
those responses Arkham Attic if you look
at some of the images that are available
in publications in particular work like
keith larry has shown patience with pet
positive tumors all around the body and
they just disappear dramatic lesions on
the skin and just disappear but
unfortunately there are side effects
although generally manageable ones which
includes claimed the cell carcinomas but
the real unfortunate part is that nearly
all patients do experience progression
and resistance in about a one to
two-year time frame so there's been a
lot of working trot underway to try to
overcome this progression in existence
and other agents have gone into
development for example finding that nib
which is also known as MEK 162 is under
review by the FDA for an Rasputin
melanoma and we'll see how the review by
the FDA proceed on that but there are
other agents as i mentioned that are in
clinical study so that's just on the
single agent front and combination
therapy seems like a way that one ought
to be able to control the side effects
and to potentially overcome some of the
resistance so the response rate lift
targeted therapy combinations is quite
good at about sixty five percent draffen
have been tormenting him based on
clinical studies appear to be superior
to them your app and it as a single
agent likewise the combination is
superior to tagrapha nin balloon based
on the clinical work the kingdom and
feminine kobe in combination superior to
them alone newer combinations are also
being explored including on carafe and
in a newer
a rap inhibitor in combination with mini
metonym so a lot of work is proceeding
in this area I just want to show you a
little bit at the clinical data to
summarize and illustrate some of the
points I made this is a trial called a
data from the comedy trial which
compared to BRAF inhibitor Magnum in the
blue line to them you're active in the
orange line and you can see that the
combination based on the overall
survival data shown here was
significantly favored tagrapha didn't
remain in and if you look at a summary
table that was published in 2015 which
kind of pulls together all of the
combination data on clinical studies
that are being updated more or less as
we speak acting as no meeting in
Copenhagen that we take place in a few
days that these combination therapies do
offer quite nice overall survival the
BRAF inhibitor mented with the longest
history with their 25 25 month caninum
OS shown at the top right but them and
Kobe and we look forward to seeing with
the data on aqua rapid and Vinny nuttin
it is he's all appear to be superior to
single engine coaches so at this point
I'm going to start to wrap up and talk a
little bit about future directions would
ask you to begin to think about
questions you may have for me but what
about future directions so the theme of
the presentation with melanoma at the
front lines and what is the evidence for
that well the use of anti pd-1 drugs
first approved in melanoma is definitely
been demonstrated has definitely been
demonstrated in other cancers in
non-small cell lung cancer in renal cell
carcinoma in lymphoma and also in having
neck cancer the pd-1 droughts that
refers to clear for melanoma are
approved by the fda produced in all of
these other munications there is very
promising data for colorectal cancer
that is mismatch repair deficient and
the hypothesis there is that in
particular cancers there are many to
relax
that are produced nitin's of fodder for
the immune system to grab ahold of and
to target a likewise in merkel cell
carcinoma a driven by local cell
polyomavirus this there is very
promising data are using anti pd-1 drugs
in this particular cancer in there are
related drugs I think of them as sister
drugs the PDL one clubs right not
targeting pd1 itself the targeting the
log and PE online and there was an fda
approval for a tease ilysm am recently
for its use in bladder cancer there is
promising data for another PDL one
antibody called abelian man in local
cell carcinoma so I think this just by
out not I think I and many others think
that the biology of harnessing immune
system through pd-1 or PDL one targeting
too disruptive checkpoint blockade is
going to have vast news and a lot of
Ellen cancers and on a targeted therapy
front I think there was my senses that
there was a little slow down in
enthusiasm for the use of these targeted
agents when the responses waned and
progression developing such their large
vaccinations but they are an important
tool in the toolkit for melanoma and
they are gaining use and greater study
and other indications that the raft MEK
inhibitor combo of de branded and
fermented showed encouraging activity in
human lung cancer and data that was
presented in the masses like recently so
I you know my my takeaways on all of
that is that we should use all of the
tools in our tool kit based on good
strong preclinical hypotheses and push
this forward into the clinic so just
wrapping up the development of them you
know and targeted therapies for melanoma
and then logical has been hypothesis
driven and built on a deep biological
knowledge but most importantly I have to
say on the commitment of some very
important researchers who remained just
later focused on the field and we're
supported by funders such as MRA to
take their work and melanoma I hope I've
convinced you as a case study not only
for precision medicine but also for it
in the no therapy and that the lessons
learned in this field are really being
applied on the front lines for not just
melanoma but for many other cancers
excellent presentation dr. Perkins thank
you thank you for bringing that
information to us before we get started
with all of your questions here's a
quick reminder about how to submit your
questions you can send your questions
via the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation wyndham and
we'll get to as many as we can within
the time allotted okay let's see oh my
apologies were just having this on minor
technical difficulties I appreciate your
patience thank you for bearing with us
um our first question dr. Perkins um we
have someone who would like on some more
information regarding combination
treatments what are combination
treatments combination the combination
treatments in melanoma include debrasse
ative internet news that's approve them
you're a fan of encoding targeted
therapy they depend on the presence of a
mutation in d600 and take a look at the
prescribing information you can see much
more detail in that the other
combination therapy that the truth for
melanoma is that it was a map and Zoey
charter Perkins um because we're dealing
with a few technical difficulties I know
you can read on the screen but if you
can on the screen um the two questions
that we had before question number one
in question number two if you could
answer those um do you mind reading the
question prior to answering it so our
audience can hear the question question
of the one was on the I don't have the
question open in front of me right now
but question number one was related to
the biomarkers for melanoma what are the
prospects for biomarkers in melanoma and
I think there's been some really
interesting work that's been done to
study PDL one as a biomarker but there
are so many opportunities in the
biomarker space that need to be explored
there are biomarkers that are specific
to individual treatments the
immunotherapy biomarkers that are being
starting include things like any of this
for the ratio of white blood cells in
the circulation to like blood cells
represented in the tumor but I can also
add that I think there is utility for
variety of biomarkers to be explored
there might be broader on the basis of
the disease itself relating to depth of
response or early relapse and so these
could be things like circulating
biomarkers that are important to monitor
the ability of any treatment to work and
when to reintroduce is Erika thermals so
those are those are some of the kinds of
things related to biomarkers that I
think are really important other
questions if you have some other
questions coming in question from dr.
our team land rover what are the what
about the interference that may be due
to the presence of pathogens in patients
presumably like a fungal infections or
bacterial infections I do not know I do
not know whether there have been any
studies on this I know there have been
concerns about the use of immunotherapy
agents in patients who have a an
autoimmune response but i think that
field is actually moving forward
relatively well and that exacerbating
autoimmune responses has not proven to
be as detrimental as one thought but it
certainly needs to be done with care I
think there was an early thought that
the anti pd-1 antibody face from their
extremely safe side effect profile we're
going to be easy to use you know almost
all exaggerated almost like aspirin they
do require some care and used to be able
to monitor and manage side of that seem
to have patients pay close attention I
had there's one other question that is
available and then perhaps we can start
to wrap up this questioner is altered
from dr. Nelson lawyer when will the
drugs be available for lower risk
melanoma patients most improved only for
the highest risk patients interferon is
only marginally helpful that has a lot
of side effects excellent question so
there's a lot of work that's going on
right now to try to understand the use
of and I'll focus on the team you won
agents but it's also true for targeted
therapies the use of these drugs in the
adjuvant setting as well as in the
neoadjuvant setting there are some
studies that I know of that are being
done with targeted therapy in the
neoadjuvant setting
I no one is he done at least been
pardoned md anderson for neoadjuvant an
adjuvant therapy of pd-1 inhibitors i
think that work is also being explored i
would say that one concern that I heard
expressed is whether the combination
therapy at the current docent those for
it me an evil letter or you know any
pd-1 in combinations and ctla-4
inhibitor the deputy approves one
whether that is appropriate to use an in
agony reimagining setting him in the
side effects and the great tree for a
citizen but I think there's a great deal
of interest in exploring the use of
these agents in earlier setting as long
as we're able to manage whatever side
effects come about and it's exactly in
this setting that he's early biomarkers
when I was talking about would be
particularly helpful because the
timelines to read out for so long yeah
if we were able to build a data set and
supported earlier readouts for these
patients that would be extremely
extremely helpful to advance the field I
would like to once again thank dr.
Perkins other presentation dr. Perkins
do you have any final comments first
want to thank the organizers for the
opportunity to present and I hope you
all agree with me that's an incredibly
exciting time not only in melanoma but
in the rest of cancer and for those of
you who are researchers on the field
thank you for your efforts and please
keep up the good work
as a reminder this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through februari 2017 you will
receive an email from us alerting you
when it's available on demand and posted
on that route you want to welcome to go
over this announcement to any colleagues
who weren't able to join in today thanks
for logging into participating in
today's broadcast see you next time
goodbye